and welcome to punch trunk sports where
winners win we have a full studio on
court us in studio a friend of show good
guy I've known for a while he is a
hustler and he's got a new album coming
out he's gonna tell us about Saint
Helberg everybody how are you I'm doing
wonderful thanks for having me
saying thanks for coming on I love you
very much you're a good friend of mine I
love your grind you're one of those
dudes who just works hard and you found
ways to get stage time cuz this town la
is really hard to get stage diamonds and
you found ways by doing it and you
basically help people by throwing comedy
shows in rehabs that's right yeah and
what you did was and you can jump in
anytime uh you just keep going you
basically tell us about your album well
my album was done in a in a state-run
lockdown jail style treat drug treatment
facility it's a dual diagnosis with like
drug addicts and schizophrenic there's a
bunch of like gangbangers and people
avoiding jail and there's like so it's
kind of like aa 5150 meets Mad Dog 2020
absolutely I like that it's gnarly in
there like no one's got their teeth a
bunch of pregnant ladies have are
hanging out there trying to get well
there's a some babies rolling around and
some some cold-blooded killers that says
to me comedy well I'll tell you what
they're the greatest audience in the
world I mean my album I'm not that funny
but they're laughing like it's a [ __ ]
laugh track it's insane they're stomping
on the floor like we do that show every
month and people come in and they're
like they pick up the chairs and bang
them on the on the ground when they
think something's funny it's wild it's
yeah I've always said that like I love
na shows AAA shows it's like you can't
find these people they shot heroin in
their dick do you think they give a [ __ ]
about jokes or not oh no they don't at
all and they love when you roast them
when you go in on them and just just
tear them apart your baby's gonna be
[ __ ] yeah they'll scream they love
that
also joining us very quietly could be
day drinking we don't know it's out
there it's it doesn't please welcome my
good friend he is one of the most
amazing fantasy football player
GM's out there our good friend Chad zoom
and zoom on from the Cleveland [ __ ]
good to be here I'm punch drunk big fan
it's been a phantom but a fan of this
show since I was a kid yeah real quick
Jason County Road dates nope okay Sam
you got a date you want push no okay
Chad is anybody working in this life
well yeah I mean if you want to get a
crippling drug addiction and go to any
one of the major rehabs in Southern
California you'll see me okay go on
chanting anything I'm at the DC Draft
House in December I don't know what the
dates are I also have an album coming
out called a white guy named Chad it
should be out I told you could push one
or two things you can't push your dates
and you already pushed the Cleveland bag
cut off of pushing he's like in the
second place and I see him last night at
the store and seen a while hug him
similar sees yeah I'm on a show tomorrow
man I might go cool we can talk about
your fantasy team to cleave the [ __ ]
and he goes did I win he looks at his
roster as much as you do tell us about
your album it's called a white guy named
Chad I taped it in Madison Wisconsin at
comedy on staff how you go Madison
Square Garden I state that a Madison
Square Garden bill burr open for me no
it was it so it's just coming out it's
gonna be an audio album because I I know
you have a special coming out Sam come
talk about that do I real quick hey
Boston I'm coming I'm at laughs Boston
this Thursday Friday and Saturday and
then I'm proud to announce myself
produce special is coming out be my big
mouth
Vimeo Vimeo and
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Oh check it out here's your chicks more
attractive the men who look like
Armenian lesbians okay big conspiracy
theorists is like the male version of
cat lady basically right everybody
thinks you're [ __ ] not just talk [ __ ]
without everybody getting a sudden you
got a gap you can do it the only color
that matters is green that's it what am
I talking about green lizard people ride
these [ __ ] cuz they're bisexual they
have a base on the moon they're making
the frogs gay okay I got peed on by
Miley Cyrus just a double that's a true
story
listen me too it's very important it was
real [ __ ] laying some [ __ ] awful
stuff but he got out control one girl I
saw I said she like he touched my bot
that's sexual assault that's not sexual
assault just like let's buy you drink
and you're walking off isn't robbery
alright zero [ __ ] will be available on
that website PayPal hey payable on
PayPal bankofamerica.com to get the
Sam's new special a bunch of people give
you venmo money you're like what's gonna
make my money back
fine are super excited finally coming
out we're to record it Sam the Viper
Room and then it called gray that's
where River Phoenix died yeah I mean too
[ __ ] up man okay this guy recorded his
out meta Square Garden in Madison
understanding the Square Garden and that
this is on the 16th this comes out and
then December 14th I believe is San
Tripoli's Merry Christmas Extravaganza
live from the Viper Room Armageddon stop
it thank you thank you thank you
so that's it so that's it it's a
wonderful time to be alive I'm so
excited it's 30 minutes across and then
the following one is about 45 minutes so
it should be fun this is my favorite
hour though this is my all my favorite
jokes the whole thing's great but I'm
excited self-produced
comedies great dude comedy is great like
I was watching uh do you guys know Matt
and you know math notes but a lot of
people don't like he's got a podcast
he's now like selling out places all
over the place I mean it's such a
wonderful time to be a comedian man
there's more opportunity than ever out
there you just gotta make it happen for
yourself he smoked me in fantasy this
week in the store no - yeah what's your
record in the store I think I'm like
middle-of-the-road I'm like 500 yeah me
too I'm five and five and in this one
I'm finally I'm finally won like two or
three in a row so I'm right in the
middle of the pack again where it was
where my finger blaster oh look at me
I'm five and twelve I'm four I'm five
more
I'm still in it did I look forward to
taking Johnny and all all the [ __ ]
fantasy leagues the cheating sack of
[ __ ] I think 500 sounds good do you
agree chat I think it sounds great so
yeah it sounds like you're killing it
where's I'm right outside we're one one
game back we're one game where are you
right here
that's not one game bad he's gets him
record as you but that's not one game
back that is that's even it Lilly says
one game back little he says it right
there do you think for a second he in
Rome would remotely Johnny does this
thing that I love and I've yet to fall
for it but I know he's gotten people
with it home win is fantasy game or
he'll be beating me in fantasy or
something and they'll send me a text hey
man my Internet's down can you look up
my fantasy score what a dick and I'm
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm looking up [ __ ]
Podcast keeps growing we got a sponsor
new sponsor shepherd.com that's this
episode's brought to you by them and
we'll get into that a little while
why wouldn't we get into it right now
the anti segue oh let's look at the
basketball league
I had Johnny dead and he went yeah he
jumped half his team and just picked up
all these players cuz he's chicken [ __ ]
only do 5 how many people are on your
team Johnny are undefeated huh yeah
where's Sam I'm tuned to I had a blast
game all the way to last second how many
games back would that make you - there
you go
Sam why don't you asked me to play it's
my favorite sport cuz I have enough
[ __ ] broken toys in this league ok I
can't have all the broken toys why are
all those names team there's no
Cleveland [ __ ] there's not because
the basketball people have bunch of
[ __ ] there's no finger blasters
laughs your name was just Sam triply
yeah sorry I regret I should change it
from finger blaster but I'm really lazy
so you Triple E yeah last night I got to
do I got to do some things burn
with Bert Kreischer and and they put me
and Gareth Reynolds together and it was
a lot of fun Gareth it's just pure fun
you just gotta get out of his way
yeah they're too quick he's [ __ ] fat
yeah
like the three fast guy no are Jason
Tebow who Gareth Reynolds and Chris
Wylde are the three I love how you
looked at him then you looked at me and
said Chris even pointed at you and Chris
Wylde you know I'm right he's great
lightning you just get out of their way
when they're on fire you know and love
girth so I went on there and it's like
jerk a gloom just get a couple laughs in
so I what did you guys eat or what did
he make I forget what it's called
potatoes you grind them up and put them
on a pear waffle grill and they put me
Charles
what pierogies yeah you make the
pierogies with him no I just literally
sat there why they cooked and I just
talked Matt yet
it was drank so then I'm like oh my
mom's in town imma bring her to this
thing so my mom shows up and they're
like oh you brought your mom I'm like I
don't worry you could say whatever you
want she doesn't care dude literally in
conversation so they're like then I'm
just figuring this chick and my mom just
like I'm like okay I didn't mean you had
to go hard in the paint like whenever I
bring a family member to a show the show
is filthier than ever
filthy I remember my arrows no longer
with us she came to this one show I did
in Phoenix and it's very legendary show
because it's when I got heckled and I
called Joe Rogan on the phone I talked
about in this movie and I'm like oh it's
gonna be fun like yeah my aunt's in the
crowd you know go you know don't worry
about it just do your thing dude the
filthiest show I've ever seen in my
mouth who else is on the show well it
was Paul Hughes and a bunch of Paul
Hughes Phoenix comics and it was just
I'm talking her [ __ ] my ass like you
know so where is that why is that I know
why she's no longer with us WOB she died
like Saturday night at the show she's
like
I'm coming to join you yeah I'm working
on a Bert Kreischer impression you want
to hear it yeah oh oh it's a girl
how's that something over there can you
do an impression of a comic without
saying an actual word just through sound
effects can we guess what comic you're
doing it's actually pretty funny when
you do it do it though say I'm doing
your presence - I could see that you
could I mean I think of one I think of
one I was thinking of you gotta sound
like that pepero for sure III want to
joke about cap and somebody running tell
him I know he'll wage war against me in
the walk hilde on a podcast yeah I you
know when he met his wife what I was
opening for capper ruler when he met his
wife
oh man how'd that go like imagine if you
would had a good set they would have
never met it was